way to go he got away I'm smelling meth
my name is Bob get away didn't we
so weekend's in the chase now you're
talking
let's get them let's go get Ambrose
welcome back to some more Deadpool ouch
[ __ ] Louis is [ __ ] here
what is this can't go [ __ ] um this
is actually kind of [ __ ] creepy
uh okay I love old 8-bit yeah me too we
do too this game is an old and since
shitty graphics haha
mr. Deadpool we ran out of money this is
one god damn it the bone again that's
hilarious
but do it nicer punch it guys what the
[ __ ] is this I can't jump anymore okay
now we should use it but but there's no
enemies that pole why should we use it
down Oh
I think I saw a unicorn what the [ __ ]
what don't swear Deadpool don't swim up
color palette I do me too okay what in
the heavens is going on seriously this
is not up games work ah
I'm sorry okay it is okay what do I do
here ah you sick what what the [ __ ] are
you guys get out of my game oh [ __ ]
Peter I was just running around my game
and I noticed that some [ __ ] was [ __ ]
up what's up with you I warned you about
the button this game is awesome and
we're sorry sweetheart
talk to the dick let me remind you that
my website got 15 million hits the
weekend we announced 1 million won 1
million this is me on YouTube hahahahaha
cough it up oh my god fireworks holy
[ __ ] this is the best stage ever made
ever
oh they die [ __ ] off
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] mail your
unicorn your lip spa with the ArcLight
go I'll hold him up
what oh oh yes
dee lives villains gotcha telephone back
in the creepy server no it's not what
are these guy got that is the moneybags
Eddie whatever they've got our mark no
mark no money to Hawaii laughing it's
shotgun time baby
well I don't know how our math is
slightly sure hey oh it's you guys
hahahaha hell did I do that honestly the
game is [ __ ] I know a lot of people
are complaining about 42 [ __ ] sweet
match the guy who's like overpowered and
[ __ ] like that but it's [ __ ] fun I'm
not gonna lie like it it's pretty badass
gameplay so far I don't know maybe not
maybe a couple hours in our show this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] doesn't die shot
going down
stupid teleport recharge this is boring
yeah nothing is happening what the [ __ ]
good there we go thank you what the [ __ ]
is she doing come ah how can we get up
yay that's what I'm talking about no I'm
not
let's purchase some items let's use the
hammers as well I know your breasts we
can have these oh my god
their next their next press ok hammer
time [ __ ] Wow come at me bro come at
me 12 these guys wow that was [ __ ]
easy huh I thought that was a boss
battle [ __ ] easiest boss battle ever
it's because I upgraded this shotgun the
maximum goddamn ah steam no not stain my
only weakness
whatever you doing good work oh here
comes the boss battle the real one
I hope what is she no way oh [ __ ] man
looking good babe yeah nice test you've
been working out but your pets
I need your breasts what hahahahahaha
pasties look unbelievable baby good
until a deal is to chill this pansy okay
she man will talk about she manically
hahahaha
boobs sorry it's just funny hi how you
doing good great come in here
so [ __ ] gave me these hammers are
awesome you they my turn
yes Teddy's you should hey Bob
those titties tank a lot
I'm trying not to be distracted Oh what
the [ __ ] are you doing
oh it's boob smacking time think you're
clever yes think you're cool yes you
ain't the only one with power a little
geek what oh now that's impressive
hey you want momentum I'll give you
momentum I want em oh it's pretty bad as
most I don't like it
and that's how we do it hey I'm only
gonna go that's [ __ ] our dicks out you
just cussed me why I'm some Rianna Falls
goddamnit
uh-oh Shh hey hot it's the pipe I was
off and gives way more pleasure oh that
is [ __ ] dog ha ha ha ha
something please
really maddis that is so [ __ ] up but
he said anyway this is pretty [ __ ] up
there almost there
this [ __ ] game is so weird
ok cool ishe Hey really no more sewers
hi moon no more sewers ha oh ok
it's Britney broke the fourth wall again
god dammit god dammit alright let's keep
playing holy [ __ ] oh come on guys
vertigo could we seriously not afford
better bad guys cause this girl's
vertical what video what a power down
switch Oh what shall I do two switches
somewhere close by
uh what oh I gotcha
sorry CSS cry she's annoying
I started to feel motion sick by this
to go got time for a hot makeout sesh
hey come back guys
we only want to kill you a little bit
all right let's get that [ __ ] okay
should we go down there I doubt it
ham ohhhhh yay ohhhhh why are they doing
that like why I guess we go in that pipe
huh look at this - thingy yeah and what
oh oh I get it
ha ha clever hi boo you think so
I don't get it doing it anyway ha ha ha
I'm ready okay go go what the [ __ ]
oh we can still go here chick gotta love
the double jump gravity dude I am love
what Oh
there's gonna be battle oh they are
autograph his feed and you BAE okay
I guess we're going up no holy [ __ ] in
this thing go
oh geez
ha ha ha why not
hailey pick one guys whoa what the [ __ ]
that guy looks [ __ ] bad
whoa calm your tits sir no water the
cops are always me with
there we go what is that sound
oh it's hahaha
slide thanks for that objective
you'd be failing pretty [ __ ] hard if
you're not sliding
funkiest [ __ ] his music I love it
nailing it whoa okay whoa whoa Jesus
healthy stuff don't worry I got it oh
yes oh my god lights are in place now
what the [ __ ] is that guy broadcasts
excellent you are no longer in use to me
bill what but but but we needed that
game's my oh gee there goes our contract
hey wait wait is that how the script
goes yeah I've had a little chat with
sinister hey there captain douche you
don't have appreciate you killing my
target before I go now I need what it is
[ __ ] shoot sorry ass what oh no
what comes love Busta Genosha awaits uh
those um those are boobies I mean but he
you x babes doing here we probably know
if we'd read the original script huh
Deadpool you need to listen to my huh
mr. sinister has taken over Chancellor
to the late we used to date
mighty jumper she's not as hot as Sylar
really we've been paying a 10-watt sorry
row you're here too i reading the
scripts like the girls said we gotta go
to Genosha if we're gonna stop mr.
sinister from wait Genosha the island
hey we'll have to fly there are we
taking the bidet the black boy I finally
wanted to fly the Blackbird no goddamn
way why did they let him ride in that
L
oh yeah uh okay see my ties works every
time
and that's why I crashed ha ha ha yeah
it seems our flight was a little more
than the ex chumps could handle okay
are they dead let's gently poke the
furry one and find out the funny one
oh there we go the time to wake up
see you to bitch-slap okay right wake up
best game ever you can bitch-slap uh
fine that's for all the car shows
that's whatever calling just say hi ha
ha ha get around with my people ha the
furry midgets in the world ha ha ha
because I feel like what whoa what Ana
wake up yeah because the player keeps
mashing the button slapping fleshy
things with this head for being in more
comics in me ha ha ha you are making me
hate you for never taking up to the prom
that's for always working late how long
is his room that's fish for stabbing me
in the heart literally that's what never
let me fly the black bird except on
aggression that's for being the worst
wingman in bromance history what because
I want to see if the player keep doing
this
ha ha ha all the hot gamer girls out
there called me that's for being a total
douche that's been ever washing the
dishes
and for last year's white elephant gift
who wants a white elephant yeah I
finally won finally
that's because the whole center of just
added five minutes of bonus play to the
most awesome game ever devised by Newton
for ya this is some quality gameplay
hahaha
looks like we're flying oh boy it's as
if I love this game designed with that
in mind
holy [ __ ] like what you don't think it's
gonna be more awesome it just [ __ ]
blows your mind
that's a great one anyway leave a like
if you enjoyed watching let me know if
you want more and I leave the lights to
it and hits the sky to fun birthday and
I'll see you next one stay awesome bros
love you haha laughs either this is a
graphic bug or is in my ass I'm vlogging
my
all right the light [ __ ] light shower
flowers Oh